Transcriber: Didem Mutan
Gözden geçirme: Sara Ozturk
Selamlar.
Biliyorum şu an hayatında işler pek
yolunda gitmiyor ve tahmin ediyorum,
çoğu zaman da zaten hayatında
işler yolunda gitmiyor.
Ama işte bazen bu zorluklarla karşılaşınca
kendine çıkış yolları arıyorsun.
Bugün ben de kendimce bulduğum o çıkış
yollarını sizlerle paylaşmaya çalışacağım.
Ama öncesinde söylemek
istediğim şeyler var.
Endonezya'nın Sulawesi adasında bir
mağarada çok ilginç bir şey bulundu.
Bundan 45.500 yıl öncesine
ait o mağarada bir çizim.
Yani biz 45.500 yıl öncesiyle
o çizim sayesinde iletişime geçtik.
Daha ilginci şu an yepyeni
bir çağ başlıyor.
Bu çağın en meşhuru sanal evrenler.
Aslında baktığınızda yine
bu evrenlerle ilk iletişimimizi,
bir çizgi aracılığıyla yaptık,
çizimle yaptık.
Buna NFT diyoruz.
Burada odaklanmanızı istediğim
şey aslında çizginin gücü.
Karikatür çizmeye ilkokul yıllarından
itibaren başladım.
Mizah dergilerinin büyülü dünyası
beni içine çekiyordu.
Beni hala bu büyülü dünyada tutansa
aslında bu bahsettiğim çizginin gücüydü.
Klişe gibi dursa da aslında
şimdi bahsedeceklerimin,
çizgi hakkında görüşlerinizi oldukça
değiştireceğini düşünüyorum.
Bugün hem çizginin gücünden
bahsederken hem de bu çizimdeki
basitlik ve sadeliğin başarısını
hayatımıza ne kadar yansıtabiliriz?
Bunun hayatımızdaki karşılığı nedir?
Biraz da onlardan bahsetmek istiyorum
aslında ama öncesinde bir karikatür
nasıl ortaya çıkar
bundan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Teknik bilgi artı fikir
diyebiliriz buna.
Yani bir şey çizmeyi biliyorsanız, biraz
pratiğiniz varsa, bir de fikriniz varsa
karikatür ortaya çıkabilir aslında.
Ama bence buna bir şey daha eklendi:
Günceli takip etmek. Bu günceli takip
etmek aslında şuradan geliyor.
Yani ilk başlarda sosyal medyada
böyle paylaşımlarım
çok paylaşılıyor, ürettiğim çizimler.
Ben de tabii ki üreten birisi olarak
ve yıllardır bu işi yapmak isteyen birisi
olarak mutluluktan havalarda gezerken
bundan babama bahsedeyim dedim.
Baba Twitter’da şu kadar kişi paylaşmış,
Instagram’da şu kadar kişi
story’sine eklemiş dedim.
Babam dikkatli ama donuk bir
yüz ifadesiyle şey demişti,
“Ben Facebook’ta görmedim.”
O zaman anlamıştım
aslında şu an kuşakların bile
kendi mecraları var.
Yani siz kuşaklara ulaşmak isterseniz bile
şu an sosyal medya gibi
kolay bir ulaşım aracılığıyla artık
oradaki mecraları da bilmelisiniz.
Şimdi kuşakların farkı dedim ama bazen
böyle toplulukta Z kuşağı arkadaşlarımla
konuşurken karikatürden konuyu açıyorum
ve arkadaşlarım genelde şey diyor.
Eski karikatürlerden böyle bahsediyoruz.
Biraz dedikodu yapıyoruz.
Şey diyorlar ya, bu mu?
Eski karikatürler falan.
Aslında biraz karikatüre ve çizime
şöyle de bakmak lazım.
Sadece bir güldürme
olarak bakmamak lazım.
Yani gülmediğiniz bir şey kötüdür,
dememek lazım.
Burada aslında şuna
dikkat etmek lazım biraz da:
Biz eski dönemlere ait herhangi
bir döneme ait bir bilgi edinebiliyorsak
aslında burada sayfalarca yazı
okumak yerine, makale okumak yerine,
kitap okumak yerine karikatür
bize şunu sağlıyor:
Tek kareyle o döneme ait birçok
bilgiyi edinebiliyoruz.
İşte burada bahsettiğim, başta bahsettiğim
o mağara duvarındaki çizim de
biz o dönemde yaşayanların
nelerden korktuğunu,
nasıl beslendiklerini anlayabiliyoruz.
İşte bu klişe gibi duran çizginin
gücünü aslında biraz da
anlamaya başlıyoruz sanki
bu örnekle birlikte.
Şimdi yine çizim sürecinden
devam etmek istiyorum.
Aslında üreten kişilere çok gelen
sorulardan bir tanesidir bu.
Karikatüristlere, çizecek bir şey
bulamayınca ne yapıyorsun?
Sonuçta bir şey üretmen lazım artık.
Bu senin işin.
Ben de bunu çok merak ettim gerçekten.
Usta çizerlere sordum, ustalarla konuştum
ve hepsinin artısı aslında ortak
tavsiyesi şuydu: Çizecek bir
şey bulamayabilirsin.
Bulamadığında kendinden yola çık,
kendinden yola çık.
Çok güzel, romantik de bir cümle bu arada.
Fakat hani günceli takip edelim dedik ya,
hadi gelin yine güncele gelelim.
Şu aralar kendimizden yola çıkmak
pek mümkün mü sanki?
Yani kendinden yola çıkmak için öncelikle
kendindeki yolların açık olması gerekiyor.
Biz şu an kendimize ne kadar
vakit ayırabiliyoruz?
Kendimizle ne kadar konuşabiliyoruz?
Bunu düşünmek lazım.
Yani kullanamadıktan sonra beş şeritli
yol olsun, pek bir şey ifade etmiyor.
Bunun örneklerini görüyoruz aslında.
Şimdi ben de bu yola çıktığım süreçte
kazandığım tecrübelerden de
biraz bahsedeceğim aslında.
Yaşadığım zorluklardan da bahsedeceğim,
ilk TEDx’ten bana
davet geldiğinde, iletişime geçtiğimizde
aslında şunu düşünmüştüm,
TEDx beni neden çağırdı?
Bunu da şu yüzden düşündüm,
şu zamana kadar gerçekten çoğunu severek,
çoğunu sevmeyerek yaptığım
o kadar farklı sektörde
o kadar farklı alanlarda
işler oldu ki mesela üniversitede
reklamcılık bölümünü
okurken aynı zamanda birçok markayla
çalışıyordum ve bu markaların etkinlik
sunuculuğunu yapıyordum,
markaları sunuyordum, sesleri oluyordum.
Dedim TEDx beni acaba
sunucu olarak mı çağırdı?
YouTube'dan izlediğimiz kadarıyla
onlarda bir sunucu yoktu.
Sonrasında lise döneminden itibaren
geçtiğimiz seneye kadar
aktif bir şekilde grafik tasarımla
uğraştım birçok markayla
dedim TEDx acaba beni
afişleri için mi çağırdı?
Afiş tasarımı için mi, bu daha mümkündü?
Çünkü TEDx’in de grafik tasarımcısı
belki konuşmacı olmuştur.
Orada bir alan açılmıştır,
o da değilmiş aslında.
Son iki senedir bütün enerjimi verdiğim
çizellik serüvenimden dolayı ulaşmışlar.
Neyse ki çünkü diğerlerinde
zaten paslanmıştım.
Bu arada son iki senedir
enerjimi verdiğim dedim
ama tamamen enerjimi
verdiğim yani aslında
karikatürü şu ana kadar hangi
işle uğraşırsam uğraşayım
bir şekilde her zaman yapıyordum.
Bunu bir iş olarak hiçbir zaman görmedim.
Tabii sadece onunla ilgilenmek istiyordum
ama herkesin zor zamanlarında kaçtığı
bazı şeyler vardır benim de karikatürdü,
hala da öyle sağolsun.
Pandeminin başlarıydı, şöyle pandemiye
götüreyim sizi ilk zamanlarda
hatta biraz ortalara götüreyim.
Oradaki böyle davranışlarınızı,
düşüncelerinizi
bir yoklamak istiyorum.
Aslında hepimiz şunu diyorduk evlere
kapandık ve insanlarla da çok görüşemedik.
Bu şekilde bize biraz avantajı
da oldu aslında bunun yani
biz kendimizle konuşmayı öğrendik.
Pandemide içimize dönmeyi öğrendik.
Ben de bu içgörü ile çizdiğim çizimlerimi
sosyal medya hesaplarımda
herkes gibi o sıralarda çok fazla
sosyal medyada vakit geçiriyordum.
Dedim yani profillerimde paylaşayım.
Kısa bir süre içinde
hatrı sayılır takipçi geldi,
paylaşımlarım milyonlarca
görüntülenme aldı.
Marka işbirliklerim bile başlamıştı ki
bu süreci ön göremeden önce bozdurduğum,
askerlik tecilim karşıma çıktı.
6 aylık bir süreçti, ilginçti.
Yani her mesleğin minimal karşılıkları
vardır, derlerdi.
Böyle bir geyik vardı aslında öyleymiş.
Ben yazın yaptım askerliğimi.
Bir gün öğle sıcağında, o yazın öğle
sıcağında, eğitimdeyken bir komutan geldi.
Biz bölükte hepimiz oturuyoruz, oturuyoruz
derken yani askeri düzende oturuyoruz
tam oturmuyoruz sonra şey dedi,
“Aranızda afiş ve posterden
anlayan var mı?”
Şimdi ben çok mutlu oldum.
Çünkü ben afiş ve posterden anlıyordum
ve o an şunu düşündüm.
Yani 6 ay boyunca askerliğim artık klimalı
bir odada tasarım yaparak geçecek.
Çünkü etrafıma baktım, elimi kaldırırken
sadece ben kaldırmışım o an şey düşündüm
böyle kendimi nasıl övüyorum
ama iyi ki bunu öğrendin,
bak işe yaradı işte
askerliğim bitti ya
falan diye düşünüyorum.
Tabi bunları düşünürken
de bir anda gidiyorum.
Yolda da şeyi soruyorlar,
iyi anlıyorsun değil mi?
İyi anlıyorum, kendimden eminim.
Sonrasında karşılaştığım manzara şuydu.
İdari işler kısmına gittik, kapı açıldı.
Bir masanın üzerinde destelerce
afiş ve poster beni bekliyordu.
Gelen emir de şuydu, bunları bölüklerin
camlarına tek tek as.
O sırada şanssızlığım da şu oldu aslında
takım arkadaşlarım öğle tatiline çıkmıştı.
O yüzden el kaldırmamak gerekiyor diye
bir geyik var ya, o da doğru.
Tabii askerlik dönüşünde her
şey çok farklıydı.
Dijital dünyada artık içerikler çoğalmış,
herkes benim gibi düşünmüş, herkes
bir şey üretmeye başlamıştı.
Kendimi hatırlıyorum da o dönemler
de şey gibi hissetmiştim,
ailesinin işinden dolayı farklı bir şehre
taşınmak zorunda kalan,
yeni sınıf arkadaşlarının bakışlarıyla
sırasına oturmaya çalışan
bir çocuk gibi hissetmiştim
ama sonrasında toparladım.
Şimdi aslında buradan da
şuna varmak istiyorum.
Bu hikayeyi neden anlattım,
bu iki hikayeyi?
Aslında şu ana kadar gerçekten çok
farklı sektörlerde işler yaptım.
Sevdiğim işi bulamadım ama şu an
sevdiğim işi yaptığımı düşünüyorum.
Sonrasında işin, sihri şurada aslında,
sonrasında bunu çizim süreciyle
bağdaştırdım, o kadar bağlantılı ki.
Şimdi çizimde belli aşamalar vardır
her işte olduğu gibi.
Eskiz dediğimiz bir aşama vardır.
Burada elinize kalemi alırsınız,
bir daire çizmek istiyorsanız
birçok daire çizersiniz.
Sonraki aşamada, çini aşamasında en
sevdiğiniz dairenin üzerinden geçersiniz
ve ortaya size en ideal bir
daire çıkmış olur.
Aslında hayatta da birçok zorluklarla
karşılaştığım, uzun dönemde eskiz
döneminde olduğumu düşündüm, yani
yaptığım her şeyin
karşılaştığım her zorluğun,
sevmeyerek yaptığım her işin de
bana bir sonraki aşamada
referans olduğunu öğrendim.
Sonra çizimi daha çok sevmeye başladım.
Şimdi burada neden durdum?
Çünkü çizginin gücüne çok değindik ve buna
bir virgül atmak istedim aslında.
Başta bahsetmiştim,
bahsedeceğimden de bahsetmiştim aslında.
Çizimde ki basitlik ve sadeliği hayatımıza
nasıl uygulayabiliriz?
Çünkü çizimde çok başarılı bir şey,
basitliği ve sadeliği uygulamak.
Bundan bahsetmek için aslında
şuna da değinmek lazım
artık hayatımızda işlerin değiştiğini,
elbet birisi işe yarar diye
oluşturduğumuz o kalabalığın,
işe yaramadığını gördüğümüzde anladım.
Yani başlığımıza bakalım bu
konuşmanın başlığına bakalım.
Aslında ben çok adam bile çizerim,
ne demek?
Herhangi bir ortamda çizer olduğumu,
karikatürist olduğumu söylediğim zaman
mutlaka birisi şey diyor:
“Ah ne güzel ya!
“Ben çöp adam bile çizemem.”
mutlaka bunu duyuyorum.
Zaten çöp adam çizmeden de pek
bir şey ortaya çıkmıyor.
Biraz önce hatırlayın o eskiz sürecini.
Öncelikle bir çöp adam çizmelisiniz ki
sonrasında ortaya bir karakter çıksın.
Zaten şu aralar, yani biraz da aslında
kendimize de çok yükleniyoruz.
Yani bundan çok bağımsız değil, onu da
girmek istiyorum ama yapamam, edemem gibi
cümleleri, yüklemleri çok kuruyoruz.
Aslında çağımızda yapacak, edecek de
o kadar çok şey var ki.
Doğal olarak yapamayacak, edemeyecek
de çok şey oluyor.
Ve ben bu sürecin başındayken
en baştan itibaren
çizemem deseydim ve şu an çiziyor olsaydım
bu gerçekten büyük bir
mucize olurdu ki mucizeler de bana göre
gerçekten hayatımızda büyük
ve boşa yer kaplayan şeylerdir.
Aslında biz neyi yapmak istiyoruz,
neyi severek yapabiliriz, biraz buna
odaklanmamız lazım ve mucizelerden
uzaklaşmamız lazım diye düşünüyorum.
Basitlik, sadelik dedik.
Bunun başarısını hayatımıza
nasıl yansıtabiliriz?
Bunu bir örnekle aslında
pekiştirmek istiyorum.
Hadi gelin Fransa’ya gidelim,
1887 yılına Paris’e gidelim hatta.
Birisinin aklında bir proje vardı
ve bir mimarı çağırdı,
Stephen Sauvestre’yı,
ve ona aklındaki projeden bahsetti.
Senden bir mimari istiyorum dedi.
Mimarımız düşündü, taşındı, çalıştı,
gecelerce sabahladı.
Muhtemelen ilk önce yakın arkadaşlarına,
yakın çevresine bu mimariden bahsetti.
Arkadaşları pek anlamadı.
Yani anlaşılacak gibi de
pek bir şey değildi.
Büyük ihtimalle etrafına bakındı
bir kalem, bir de kağıt aldı
ve aklındaki mimariyi çizdi.
O an arkadaşları ne tepki
verdi bilmiyorum.
Fakat şu an dünyanın en ünlü yapıları
arasında olan Eyfel Kulesi ilk defa
o birkaç basit çizgiyle orada hayat buldu.
Çok uzak bir örnek olduysa
yakına da gelebiliriz aslında birazdan.
Birisi sizden yol tarifi istedi.
Siz de böyle tam sözle
anlatsanız olmayacak.
Etrafınıza bakındınız, bir
kalem bir de kağıt aldınız.
Basit çizgilerle o yeri çizdiniz
ve o kişi hedefine ulaştı.
Basitti ama hedefine ulaştı.
Burada şunu da atlamamak lazım aslında
basit, basit de değildir pek.
Basit ama hedefine ulaşan fikirler ise
bana göre eğlenebildiğiniz
bir kaostan ortaya çıkar.
Bunu da atlamamak lazım.
Biliyorum, hayatında şu an işler pek
yolunda gitmiyor.
Hatta tahmin ediyorum,
çoğu zaman da işler yolunda gitmedi.
Fakat artık hayatının eskiz döneminin
olduğunu bilebilirsin.
Ve artık şunu da biliyorsun, bir sonraki
aşamada çini aşaması var
ve şu an attığın her çizgi bir sonraki
aşamada sana büyük bir referans olacak.
Bir ustam şey derdi, çizim sürecinde
böyle yeni başlayanlara
çizemezsin, çizemezsin, çizersin.
Aslında burada biraz neye
enerjimizi vermemizle alakalı.
Bir enerjimiz var, çok yoruluyoruz
ama neye enerjimizi
vermek istiyoruz o önemli.
Şunu da unutma bu arada sen
çöp adam bile çizebilirsin.
Zaten çöp adam çizmeden pek bir şey olmaz.
Sadece bunu severek
yapıp yapmadığımızla alakalı.
Bir işi severek yapmanın sonunda
bizi gerçekten büyük ödüller
de bekliyor bu arada.
Ama bir işi sevmeden yapmanın cezasını da
bizzat zaman o şeyi uzatarak veriyor.
Teşekkürler.